dann gab es gerade noch einen wichtigen
aber auch niederschmetternden jahrestag
vor zehn jahren wurde der nsu der
nationalsozialistische untergrund
gestoppt also ich muß korrigieren die
haben sich selber gestoppt anders ging
es nicht weil leider keiner nach ihnen
gesucht hat bernhard mundlos und schärpe
ermordeten 10 mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger weitgehend unbehelligt von
deutschen behörden ist wirklich einer
der größten skandale der nachkriegszeit
zum jahrestag gab es mehrere kleinere
gedenkveranstaltung allerdings und
glauben sie mir wir haben lange
gegoogelt ohne einen einzigen
prominenten deutschen politiker aber
klar die haben natürlich auch andere
termin in der frau merkel zum beispiel
ist ja gerade auf abschiedstournee die
war in griechenland frankreich oder hier
im vogelpark marlow
man weiß wirklich nicht wer sich unwohl
fühlt
sie oder die papageien aber das nur am
rande außerdem hätte man sie bei
gedenkveranstaltungen vielleicht an ihr
versprechen von damals erinnert sie
wissen ja noch wir würden alles tun die
morde aufzuklären ja genau so tragik
gehört schon
1997 lagen gegen uwe böhm hat mehrere
haftbefehle vor die vorhandenen
haftbefehle gegen bernhard wurden nicht
vollstreckt weil man zum jahreswechsel
97/98 gegenüber bernhard seitens der
staatsanwaltschaft einen
weihnachtsfrieden geltend machen wollte
schöne geste oder ein staatsanwalt hat
ihm sogar weihnacht socken gestrickt mit
so kleinen ss runen drauf und als man
ende januar 98 endlich zugreifen wollte
war das terror trio leiter bereits im
untergrund ja blöd blöd ja ohne
ohne der polizei bescheid zu sagen
extrem unhöflich von denen es gab sehr
sehr früh wenn man genau hinguckt sehr
viele gelegenheiten zu erkennen was sich
da zusammenbraut im jugendclub begann
die freundschaft zwischen beate treppe
und uwe mundlos nicht absehen bodenlos
rausgeschmissen 290 das ging einfach
nicht mehr der tauchte in der ist auch
die form of im klub ja nie form ist oft
ein erstes indiz für rechte gesinnung
andererseits aus prinz harry ist ja
später auch noch was geworden
40 v leute 40 v leute verschiedener
behörden waren jahrelang in direkten
umfeld des nsu im einsatz trotzdem
konnte kein einziger mord verhindert
werden ist eine schande klar auch weil
die polizei konsequent in die falsche
richtung ermittelt hat die sogenannte
soko bosporus wurde eingerichtet und im
boulevard stand was von boehner morgen
dann müsste man ja bei tötungsdelikten
ganz ohne migration bezug konsequent von
kartoffel morgen sprechen macht man ja
auch nicht
absurderweise und ganz
selbstverständlich wurden die opfer von
der polizei erst mal automatisch für
täter gehalten zu dem zeitpunkt war die
vorherrschende thema durch die
sogenannte organisations theorie was aus
sagt dass die opfer entweder mitglieder
einer kriminellen organisation waren
oder von einer kriminellen organisation
letztendlich bedroht worden sind
geständig sagte aus dass der typ blond
war die polizei hat mich aber direkt
gefragt ob es nicht eher ein dunkler typ
sein könnte das war viel besser weil
sonst wirst du ja ganz von vorne
ermitteln wobei natürlich das gehört so
weit der verfassungsschutz damals gegen
die polizei gearbeitet hat es
tatsächlich zu der verfassungsschutz hat
er da in der rechten szene seine v-leute
in der regel hardcore nazis also man
könnte auch sagen verdeckte ermittler
und
ja und der schutz dieser v leute war
leider wichtiger als das verhindern von
morden der thüringer
untersuchungsausschuss und das müssen
sich auf der zunge zergehen lassen sieht
klare indizien dass der geheimdienst die
ergreifung des trios aktiv sabotiert hat
immerhin gab es beim bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz in köln letzte woche
eine veranstaltung zum thema zehn jahre
nsu skandal wo sie ja gefeiert haben das
bis heute nichts wesentliches
ausgekommen ist da wurden alte nsu akten
benutzt um würstchen zu grillen und für
stimmung auf dem dancefloor sorgte dj
hans georg persönlich ja und zum schluss
haben sie dann noch eine runde blinde
kuh gespielt oder wie die sagen blinder
bulle so heißt das bei
verfassungsschützern und während zb die
nsu akten in hessen für 30 jahre
gesperrt sind bleibt man offiziell bei
der drei täter theorie dabei sagen alle
relevanten experten das kann nicht sein
es kann nicht sein es muss
es muss ein unterstützernetzwerk gegeben
haben überlegen sie mal wie bedrücken
muss das für die angehörigen der opfer
sein dass diese leute diese unterstützer
immer noch frei herum laufen mitten
unter uns war aber den
ermittlungsbehörden von anfang an eher
egal
sind die fehler der behörden dann nicht
noch viel entscheidender gewesen wenn
man ein ganzes netzwerk mit einem
grösseren umfeld nicht entdecken konnte
das nenne ich mal an der falschen stelle
gegrinst ja und damit wir uns nicht
missverstehen auch in zukunft kann der
verfassungsschutz natürlich nicht auf
v-leute verzichten weder in der
islamistenszene noch in der linken oder
rechten und ihnen es sicherlich klar
weil es als nächstes rauskommt oder ja
alles v leute ja
beobachten sich den ganzen tag
gegenseitig wobei ich an dieser stelle
einfach mal zugeben muss ja auch die
heute show hat seit jahren ein mann bei
der afg eingeschleust und sie haben
wahrscheinlich wählen
[Gelächter]
man muss es raus kommen
jetzt legen die fakten auf den tisch der
bernd ist in wirklichkeit comedy autor
bei der heute show und heißt eigentlich
björn björnsson
vor gericht muss ich das allerdings
leugnen der nsu skandal auch nach zehn
jahren immer noch ein krimi
beziehungsweise ein quiz
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu wer weiß denn
sowas zehn jahre später immer noch nicht
mit klaus von pflaume
unser total und lustiges christ zu allen
noch offenen nsu fragt es ist
unglaublich untersuchungsausschüsse in
acht landtag und im bundestag aber wir
wissen immer noch nichts auch mein
kandidat der oliver weiß absolut nichts
dass filmt hallo und wir erlegen gleich
mal los oliver nach der selbst
enttarnung des nsu wurden beim
verfassungsschutz hunderte akten
vorgänger vernichtet welcher schredder
oder welche schritte aktion war denn die
kekse die beiden antwortmöglichkeiten
sind jetzt eingeblendet
er verfolge die sind aber beide
geschwärzt wie schade dann wären die
ersten 30 jahren wieder freigegeben kein
punkt für oliver was ja richtige antwort
am lustigsten war es beim berliner
verfassungsschutz womöglich brisantes
also landete im reißwolf weil alten
geheimschutz raum fakten kartons
sortiert wurden ausgerechnet der
referatsleiter rechtsextremismus links
und rechts verwechselt haben soll
rechts ist da wo der nazi links ist kann
man sich ganz gut merken nächste frage
mundlos und boehner hat töten sich 2011
in ihrem wohnmobil hier mal ein modell
mit zwei playmobil uwes drin frage was
passierte als erstes am tatort ja ich
würde sagen eine akribische
spurensicherung dna analysen als in der
ganzen ist ihr seid ja
fast passiert ist folgendes
das ding wurde mit den leichen drin auf
einem abschnitt wagen durch zwickau
gekarrt
und alles ist ein bisschen durcheinander
geflogen während andere spezialisten
sich gründlich um die von beate schiffer
angezündete wohnung des trios gekümmert
haben mit schwerem gerät wird das
zentrum der wohnung heraus gerissen
übrig bleibt ein besen rainer tatort
das ergibt doch sinn niemand mag
dreckige tatort
wieder kein punkt für oliver sie haben
mich doch zur wohnung gar nichts gefragt
wozu auch sie wissen ja nix stimmen
auch nicht über andreas thema diesen
hessischen verfassungsschützer der rein
zufällig beim kasseler nsu mord am
tatort war also während der mord an
halles joschka passiert ist dann sagt er
habe keine schüsse gehört und beim
bezahlen auch nicht den toten gesehen
der direkt neben ihm auf dem boden lag
übrigens hatte terry in seinem dorf den
spitznamen klein agris was das kann
alles mögliche bedeuten ja ja ja seine
v-leute dürfte die staatsanwaltschaft
ausdrücklich nicht verhören frage wie
ist es mit temme anschließend weiter
gegangen wurde er aus dem
beamtenverhältnis entlassen oder ist der
b nach alter väter sitte richtung
argentinien geflüchtet
da hoffe ich gott sie wisse wirklich
überhaupt nichts
nachdem die ermittlungen gegen ihn
eingestellt wurden bekam der
verfassungsschützer temme der nichts
gewusst nichts gehört und nichts gesehen
haben will einen neuen job ausgerechnet
in der abteilung beamtenversorgung
bitter bitter bitter insgesamt null
punkte für oliver und er hatte sich so
gefreut auf unseren hauptpreis das
romantik wochenende in zwickau
aber die sendezeit ist leider um dabei
hätte ich noch so viele offene fragen
gab woher hatten die terroristen die
adressen von rund 10.000 anschlagszielen
warum hatte stefan ernst der mörder von
walter lübke gleich mehrere bekannte aus
dem direkten nsu umfeld zu fall aber vor
allem wie viele unterstützer des terrors
laufen da draußen immer noch frei herum
das erfahren sie nächste woche in
unserem neuen kreis gefragt aber
überhaupt nicht gejagt
und das läuft um die uhr oliver das war
sie auch nicht groß vom schlauer meine
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liegt - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist mine der stelle
[Musik]